i asked a question to the universe which
then my cells answered i asked a
question when i just realized and owned
i exist as a
field energy a spirit whatever you want
to call it as information in the field
and i also exist as a body
my first question that came up in my
head was then why have both why have a
spirit and a body why not just be the
spirit
and my cells
came up with this chorus that i just
blasted my head and it was kind of funny
because i i think they have jewish
heritage cells because i asked them a
question and they responded in a
question
i asked why have both
and all of a sudden it welled up and the
answer came and said bruce
if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden i said oh my god
it's the biology which is all the
receptor devices that translate my
environment into sensation which are
then translated by the nervous system
into fields and and vibrational patterns
which are then sent back to my source
and i realized at that moment i said
my god that we're here to experience
this place to touch it and smell it
watch sunsets and feel love and and and
and eat wonderful food and have all this
and i thought wow and then all of a
sudden i said yeah but it's not just
receiving information
when you have a body you can be creative
we can come to this planet and manifest
creativity
and we do this we step into a virtual
reality suit called the body i step into
the suit as a spirit
it communicates with me via just the
same way the mars rover is communicating
with nasa
and i get to experience this planet if i
have a picture of fear in my mind i'm
afraid of something my brain translates
fear with different chemicals stress
hormones cortisol norepinephrine
factors that affect the immune system
that are called cytokines or histamine
so basically in a state of conscious
fear the brain releases chemistry that
complements fear that chemistry goes
into the body's blood and that changes
the behavior and the genetics of the
person
so that means there's a difference
between having positive thoughts and
having negative thoughts
and people say oh that positive thinking
doesn't really work but that's not true
the best example of positive thinking in
a scientific study is called placebo you
have a disease and doctor says here's
this new pill and it's the brand new
science and it's going to cure you and
you believe it
and you take the pill and you get well
then you find out the pill was a sugar
pill
so then you're left with
so what made me well it's not the sugar
pill it was the positive belief in that
sugar pill and how it's going to help
your life
so that's called placebo positive
thinking positive result
unfortunately most people don't
recognize a more important point
negative thinking is equally powerful
but it works in the opposite direction
so it turns out for example
less than 10 percent of cancer is even
connected to a family lineage
90 of cancer just comes out of the blue
so to speak but the reality is no it's a
result of stress and negative thinking
so it's important point positive
thinking negative thinking equally
powerful because that's the level of
consciousness that is translated into
the chemistry that controls your
genetics
i just want to add a very important
point to this quantum physics is the
most valid science on this planet there
is no science that has been tested more
and verified more i guess so what's the
relevance because the primary principle
in quantum physics is consciousness is
creating our life experiences and well
when you add epigenetics to that physics
now we understand the mechanism of how
consciousness is controlling our biology
so biology and physics are coming
together to reveal that we are very
powerful creators of our lives the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind i say
what's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are
in that conscious mind and perceiving
the world i say what about the
subconscious mind it's not a creative
mind the subconscious mind is habits
things that you've learned and you
experienced in your life and they become
habits so
the subconscious mind is not thinking
creating a subconscious mind push the
button
play the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say
oh i wish i had this and i desire that
and these are the things i want and then
you go out and start the day and then
guess what
95
of the day
you are not operating from the conscious
mind science is recognized 95 of the day
because we are thinking 95 of the day
our behavior is now controlled by the
subconscious mind
i go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is
the conscious mind with your creativity
has your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people
your mother your father your siblings
and your community so what is the
difference
you wake up with a wish and a desire of
what you want
and then the rest of the day
you play the programs that you got from
other people that don't answer your
wishes and don't support your desires
and all you see is the consequence of it
and go oh my god why is it not working
the answer is because you don't see
because remember the name is
subconscious
below conscious
so when that behavior is playing
psychologists will tell us
70 percent or more
of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see
is the consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage
all the desires and wishes you have
and then to conclude that
what if you just didn't
default to the subconscious what if you
just stayed in the conscious mind that's
called being mindful
and why is it relevant because when you
stay
conscious keep your mind present
you are the creator of your life and
when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion
you're really running your life with
your programs acquired from other people
in our mind we start to realize that
we're concerned we're afraid we don't
have enough i'm not safe i'm not secure
and i say oh these thoughts i was
talking about the thoughts in your mind
go in and control your biology your
genetics your physiology and your health
and i go yes this is really true
i said well how can i tell you what your
thoughts are in a sense that can i read
your thoughts and i say yes you know i
could put wires on your head and it's
called
electroencephalograph and i could read
your brain activity and i go oh great i
can see this brain activity
i want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were
programmed to believe that our thoughts
are contained in our head
that if i have a thought it's just for
me not for anybody else it's inside and
it's working through me
and now i want to tell you about a new
technology it's not electro
encephalograph it's called magneto
encephalograph
i say what's unique about that i say
read your brain i say yeah but so does
eeg i say yeah but eeg you put the wires
on the head and you get the electrical
activity conducted through the skin from
the brain and that's what i'm reading
and i said what's different about emig
the probe
is out here
and i said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head
your thoughts are broadcast to the field
just like a radio broadcast
i say well what if i as an individual
have a thought that says
let's have peace in the world
and i broadcast out there in the street
and i say let's have peace and i look
around it's like
where's the peace i don't see the peace
and here's what the relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field i say your energy is in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go what does that mean and then i'll
give you this most wonderful quote
i used it the other day in a lecture
from albert einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field
so definite the definition the field is
the invisible energy right now you're in
a field there's cell phone broadcast
television television radio broadcast
all kinds of information coming across
but guess what each one of you is a
broadcast in that field the quote
the field
is the sole
governing agency of the particle
particle is the material realm
so what was einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives
and if enough of us collectively have an
energy that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast a belief
we change the world
i just want you to recognize as much as
i wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if i want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced
that the war is going to benefit them so
that their broadcast say yes let's have
a war because i and my colleagues we're
all going to have a better result from
that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga
when you're in your postures when you're
in your process your mind is sharing a
thought not just in your head
but all around you
so the whole idea about this is we have
to recognize
we are collectively
creating reality with our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking
you get enough people to say peace there
will be peace instantly in this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to
give them the power to tell us what we
need
and assad fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and i really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field
and that thought the field is the sole
governing agency of matter
and therefore
what this world is looking for at this
moment is an evolution
it's not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough
it will end the problem with the concept
of power
the power of positive thinking is people
just think oh well if i just have
positive thoughts then my life should be
affected and and this is why positive
thinking has a real bad rap in the
public and the reason is this having a
positive thought does not in any way
necessitate that those positive thoughts
actually manifest themselves and there's
a piece that was left out and if you
don't understand the piece then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this
when you're having positive thoughts
you're using your mind
the new biology reveals that the
invisible forces
that collectively we refer to as mind
that these form a field which shape
biology
well here's what's important yes the
mind influences biology but there are
two parts to the mind that are
completely different than one another
yet they work together we confuse them
we tie them together and yet they
represent two entities working in two
different fashions there's the conscious
mind
and what is called the subconscious mind
now here's what the very important
people have to know this okay and here's
what it is
the conscious mind is our creative mind
that is connected to our personal
identity and our spiritual selves that's
that makes us all unique our each of us
has our own personal conscious mind but
what becomes very significant is this is
the subconscious mind
is equivalent to a tape player it's
exactly what it is it records
experiences and then plays them back
and and so now let's take a look and say
well wait there's a thinking mind
and then there's a tape player mind and
what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first
the
tape player the subconscious mind
as an information processor as the
equivalent of a computer
is a million times more powerful on an
information processor than it's a
conscious mind so when you look at the
power between the conscious and
subconscious subconscious a million
times more powerful
number two
on a date by day basis
the subconscious mind runs our biology
about 95 to 99 of the time
so while you're having all these
wonderful thoughts
that's not the conscious the conscious
mind is not running the show it's a
subconscious mind then it comes the
issue is well the subconscious mind got
programs in it yes and the and the
subconscious mind is not evil or good
the subconscious mind is a tape player
as much as you can say okay here here's
a tape player it's good or bad it's not
the tape player is not good or bad
the programs can be good and the
programs can be bad so blaming the
subconscious mind as a negative thing is
that's the first mistake it's a tape
player
the programs that we got that's the
source of the problems that most of us
face
and these programs could limit our
abilities and take away our powers which
essentially they do
now the relevance about positive
thinking is this
positive thinking is a creative thought
that comes from the conscious mind
okay so i sit here and i'm going to have
all these wonderful thoughts i'm going
to close my eyes and visualize all these
wonderful things
now stop and go back to the mechanical
character of it a i'm having these
thoughts with a little tiny processor
called the conscious mind
and i'm competing with the programs that
are in the subconscious mind
so if i have a thought for
being being healthy or being in a good
relationship
and i'm doing positive thinking and at
the same time i've acquired programs in
my development that said you're not as
healthy as you think you are and you
you're not that good a person to have
those kind of relationships then look
i'm now putting my positive thoughts
against my programs and and they're in
their opposite
but this one works on a little tiny
processor and this process is a million
times more powerful so right away it's
like who's going to win in that
challenge the answer of course the
subconscious is going to win okay but
here comes the other part
while i can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than five percent of the day
that says 95 or more of the day i'm
operating from the other belief system
the point is do the math
how powerful are positive thoughts and
the answer is
unless the subconscious has the same
programs and agreement as the conscious
mind power of positive thinking will not
work
it will not work because you're
competing against a much more powerful
processor the belief that is taught is
that biology in the world we live in
operates according to newtonian
principles
unfortunate part about that is quantum
mechanics 100 years ago said that's
obviously not true and physicists know
this is not true and yet medicine
doesn't buy into it because it still
focuses on the material reality and lets
go of the invisible shaping fields that
quantum physics emphasizes as primary
okay so we got we have to change that
belief system we have to get people to
recognize that the field and the
thoughts and all these other things are
as important as anything else in shaping
the matter we live in number two
the belief which i you know i blew away
years ago but it's still being taught in
school is the concept that genes control
life
this is totally false genes control
nothing control is an action
a gene is a blueprint it's a
physically literally a string with
blueprint data on it
why is that relevant
it's interesting go to an architect's
office
and the architect's working on a
blueprint and then lean over the
architect's shoulder and say is that
blueprint on or off
and he looks at you
the blueprint's not on or off as a
blueprint yeah but we talk about genes
being on and off like genes are turning
on and genes are turning off and the
question is but genes are blueprints
they can't turn on and off there is no
on and off it's just the blueprint it's
a pattern
what we have failed to focus on because
we gave genes a character of
self-actualization
that my genes decided to do something
it's like okay now we're a victim of the
genes but it turns out biologists know
that this is not true biologists know
that genes are not turned on and off
genes are red or not red like blueprints
then all of a sudden it says well it's
not the blueprint that's important if
the blueprints were self-actualizing an
architect could go by a building site
drop the blueprints off come back two
weeks later and the building will be
there that's what we think about
animals and plants uh the genes are
blueprints and their control all this is
like no
the blueprints are important i'm not
saying they're not you've got the bad
blueprints you've got some problems
going on here but the issue is it's not
the presence or absence of a blueprint
it's whether the blueprint is being read
and then you say well then who reads the
blueprint the answer is a contractor
and who's the contractor
the mind is the contractor the mind
reads genes the mind can change the
genes read out here here's something so
blow away that most people can't in
their conventional world make sense of
it because it's it's like ah it goes
like this
the mind through what is called
epigenetic mechanisms
can
start with a single gene blueprint
and create over 30 000 different
versions of products from the same
blueprint 30 000 different products from
the same blueprint all of a sudden you
realize my god
you can infinitely vary the expression
of the gene and the answer is yes
and why is this become relevant to all
of us and the answer is because many of
us think genes control our lives and yet
we don't realize that we modify the
readout of the gene so we could be
totally healthy and our mind can cause
cancer our mind can cause any disease
diabetes anything like that
and and what's interesting is the flip
side
is some people come here with actually
defective genes
and guess what with their mind they can
rewrite those genes and make them normal
so the genes are not the limiting factor
it's the mind something you look at in
spontaneous evolution too is how
science and spirituality are coming
together they used to be very separate
absolutely there's the scientific world
which is very factual driven and that's
that and you couldn't change it and
spirituality was trying to open up
things but they really are meeting now
aren't they yeah it was interesting
because um the spiritual world of
religion was talking about the invisible
moving forces that shape the physical
reality and we call them spirit
and then science
only came into existence because it made
a de taunt with the church in the very
early days of science it said look
we won't tread on your invisible
spiritual domain we will just study the
physical world and when newton was able
to predict the movements of the planet
by just looking at the physical features
then scientists got the ideas well if
you can understand how the universe
operates by just studying the material
world we don't need that invisible stuff
but in 1925
newtonian physics was
incorporated subsumed by a bigger
physics called quantum physics and
quantum physics emphasizes the universe
is made out of energy it's not made out
of matter and then i say well what does
the quantum physicist call this energy
that the universe is made out of i say
well they call it the field i said
what's the definition of the field i
love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world i go
my goodness that's the same definition
as spiritual it's used for spirit i go
yes quantum physics emphasizing the
invisible uh field as primary to the
physical world
is essentially reiterating
the statement of the spiritual people
who talked about the invisible forces
shaping our physical existence and so by
definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality uh
hopefully
uh the the dogmatic beliefs of the
church which had uh talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there
and science which is still stuck in its
material plane will both divest
themselves of their dogma
and allow us to come together and
recognize that we're all
part of that invisible field that
we don't even live in our own bodies if
you understand the nature of how the
cell works so we are part of the field
being downloaded into our body that
we're all by definition the field or
we're all spiritual same definition
and and if we recognize this the unity
of it and that you cannot be taken out
of the field and you cannot be in a
sense punished by the field you are the
field
then maybe the beliefs those very
restrictive beliefs from both science
and from the dogmatic religion
will disappear
because the people owning their own
spirituality owning their own
responsibility
and not saying oh which spirits that did
this or things other factors that we are
the creators
will generate a new world because what i
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world
and say if you could create a world what
would you like well i'd like a world
where there's peace and harmony and i
like some food and a job and i go isn't
it amazing how everywhere you go in the
world virtually entire population has
the same belief i go then how come we
don't have any answers because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so i trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world
and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together
we will create magic on this earth like
nothing has ever been seen before so i'm
very optimistic about that the hardest
part about programming
that people don't recognize is you have
to make all programs
present tense
statements
not future statements
i will have i shall have you know
something like that say no i am
it is
and the reason is it's so logically
simple that is this
uh let's say i'm not well i say i want
to be well and i say fine let's record
that oh now let's come back a whole year
later and push the button that says i
want to be well i say oh it's been a
whole year
you never got there you just wanted to
be well for a whole year that's what the
program said so if you are sick
and you write i am healthy
and the mind looks at the program says
oh i got to change this it doesn't
change the program it brings health back
so that the body matches the program
and so
that that's the whole issue about it the
function of the mind is to take the
program and manifest it and if you've
got a negative program then obviously
whatever manifests is going to be
negative
the thing that we often forget is that
we're all miracle workers wherever we
are
you're not just a miracle worker
or if you want to call it a light worker
or whatever you want to call it
if you're working as a life coach or
you're a therapist or you're a speaker
or writer or whatever it is
you're every where we go is a moment to
offer someone a shift in their
perception which is a miracle everywhere
we go is a moment to
help
transcend the limitations of the world
and be a force of good in the presence
of another human
so
start now
where you are
and then let the universe
show you what to do
because
we start to get into how do i get there
what am i going to do
the overthinking and the plotting and
the scheming
gets in the way of the allowing
so be in the work
do the work in every encounter at the
grocery store
at the doctor's office at your job on a
zoom
be the light wherever you go
excellent
so you're already doing it you got your
yoga classes
keep doing what you're doing keep
bringing that light with you wherever
you go and i guarantee you
the universe will reveal to you the next
action and the next action and the next
action so i actually don't want you to
try to figure it out i want you to stay
in the momentum of what you've already
created which is that you're bringing it
to the yoga class you're bringing it to
the office you're bringing it to the
home you're bringing it to your
friendships
it will be revealed to you i guarantee
you
that's the whole point that's the whole
point
there's a lot of practical things that
you could you could do if you're like i
want to go build a business whatever
sure there's a million ways you could do
that but i
i think right now is your moment by the
way one of my signs was a check mark and
somebody just put a check mark in the
thank you for my sign thank you thank
you thank you out there for the check
mark okay so i um
baby baby baby
i believe you
i feel you i trust you that you are here
to bring a lot of love and to teach in
your own unique way
i don't want you to overthink it i don't
want you to get in the way of it i don't
want you to start too soon in the sense
of leaving your job or whatever i want
you to be
in the daily devotion of how can i serve
in every corner of your life and get
that fully and completely and that's
when there's more checkmarks and that's
when
you are going to
be very very very clear about what the
next right action is for you i mean it i
really mean it i think that when we're
trying to bring a new energy into the
work that we do or into our
relationships or anything in our life if
we get too
heady about it and too logical about it
and too detailed about it at first we
actually get in the way of what it can
be
the details and logic and all that can
come but i want you to right now in this
moment be super grounded in
how can i serve it at my yoga class more
how can i serve in this existing job
more and as you start to do that you'll
be very v it'll be very clear to you and
revealed to you have you ever seen a
mustard seed here i have some here
i want to pull one out now jesus said if
you had the faith of a mustard seed you
could move mountains
and anything was possible now i heard
this as a kid and i really believed it
and so the question is what do you
believe
do you believe that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness success
abundance
comfort fulfillment peace
joy
love is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe
or do you believe something else because
you will
manifest
the life that you believe visualization
is one of the great secrets of success
that's where we build a picture in our
mind
when van gogh was asked how do you do
such beautiful work he said i dream my
painting and then i paint my dream
well that's the way it works
um all the great leaders have been great
visionaries
and
solomon said where there is no vision
the people will perish now that doesn't
mean they're going to die it just
means their results are going to get
weaker and weaker and weaker and they're
just not going to be making it happen
the way they want to
everyone visualizes whether he realizes
or not
visualization is a great secret to
success now look at this
the conscious use of this great power
attracts attracts to you
multiplied resources multiply it
attracts to you
you know something about the law of
attraction how do we attract well
through visualization
now look it
and it intensifies your wisdom and
enables you to make use of advantages
you formally fail to recognize the
universe in some way is kind of a little
bit rigged against us that's correct let
me prove to you
he's a garden now when you plant roses
what do you get
what do you get
comment below you get roses right
now what happens if you don't plan
anything and you don't take time to even
take care of the garden you even pay
attention to it what happens
weeds grow
so it is not the case that if you
don't plan something nothing will happen
no it's rather the case when you don't
plan anything
weeds grow and that's how our mind works
so if you're not constantly feeding your
mind i call that mind feed if you don't
constantly feed your mind with
positive motivation inspiration
something
something that moves you towards your
goals practical useful
information to feed your mind if you're
not doing that constantly weeds grow and
that's why personally i don't watch news
because most news are nothing more than
negativity and they are just
designed to grab your attention right
the design is just sensations it doesn't
actually do much to your life it doesn't
add value to your life it doesn't make
you a better person except it scares the
heck out of you you watch enough news
you don't even want to go out right you
don't want to do anything so i don't
watch news if it's important enough
guess what my team someone would tell me
i'll eventually find out but most of the
time i don't know what is going on i
focus on what i do i want to protect
this
i want to protect my filter i'm very
very careful about
how i view the world and how i upgrade
my filter and that's why law of
attraction it works all the time it
works 24 7. you cannot stop it even if
you want to you cannot stop it even if
you're not paying attention to it so you
could choose
you can choose what information you
consume every single day you can choose
what you pay attention to you can choose
what channel you watch you can choose
what videos you watch you have the power
to choose most people never manifest
their ideas because you don't trust your
ideas that bold idea that came to you
that made sense to you in the moment the
next day feels too bold too crazy too
insane to not for someone like you i
believe that the decisions that come to
you when you're feeling bold are
actually the right ones for you and you
have to take immediate action on because
otherwise your head gets in the way and
talks you down from doing the things
that you should be doing so right now
i'm in the process of looking for a
creative director for my business
someone to look at all my content
suggest ways to make it better to to
be focused on the branding and
opportunities for me and this was a
suggestion from mark draker friend of
the channel a long time personal friend
of mine as well he helped fill my very
first video he's the reason why i did
top 10 moves to success
long story with mark and he said evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or brand
manager or ceo somebody to be in charge
of all the creative decisions and
getting me out on the stages that they
need to be out on so how do we make
these videos better that's that person's
role and so in my head
when he first said it i'm a little
afraid i'm scared like
how do i find this person i need to vibe
well with them i don't i can't just
bring anybody into that role i'm a
pretty weird duck and so this has to be
a good you know long-term fit for me how
much is this person going to cost how do
i fit into my cost structure right now
with my business how are we going to
deal with conflicts it's all of the
negativity all of the things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on this is a
bold idea and i need to at least explore
it i need to try it i need to play it
out maybe it works maybe it doesn't but
teaching yourself teaching myself that i
do bold things i do scary things i do
difficult things and being scared is not
a good enough reason for not to take
action and so those ideas that come to
you trust that they came to you for a
reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man i
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan plan you're
going to spend all your best energies
just stuck in planning mode instead of
actually going up and taking action
you're going to tell your friends about
it they're going to tell you it's a
stupid idea you're going to sleep on it
you're going to wake up and tell
yourself it's a stupid idea and then
what happens is no momentum the biggest
thing that is missing from your life
is momentum
nina's happy and is smiling she's next
to me filming that's all that's missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great genius amazing ideas you're just
missing momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself why you
can't do it instead of going off and
proving to yourself that you can so how
do you find the ideas and then how do
you take action on them i'm going to
give you a three-step process step
number one is go for a walk have a
shower do whatever the thing is that
makes you feel
energized creative and in the zone right
if you're constantly just in front of
your phone and stressed out all day long
you're not gonna come up with creative
ideas so where do you get creative ideas
i get creative ideas when i'm driving i
get creative ideas when i'm in the
shower i get creative ideas when i'm
walking i don't really meditate so i
don't get ideas when i'm doing that but
it's it's time when there's nothing
scheduled and so do you have enough time
during your week or during your day
that is open that you allow yourself to
think and be creative
for a lot of people watching this you
probably do you probably have some
moments in your calendar that are
dedicated to at least having a shower
hopefully hopefully you have showers on
a regular basis right so you're coming
up with ideas right so whatever that
thing is that lets you come up with
ideas do more of it right if you get
great ideas in the shower maybe instead
of a five minute shower take a 15 minute
shower maybe you get some more ideas
coming to you right you want to you want
to spend more time doing the work that
generates creativity for you that's step
number one step number two is don't
judge the ideas that come to you this is
where so many people fall down you get
an idea and then you judge it and you
say i can't do that i'm not good enough
i don't have the money i know the
connections i didn't go to school for
that i'm not tall enough i'm not pretty
enough i'm not smart enough whatever
people like me don't do this thing all
these ideas why you can't win you're
telling yourself why you can't win
before you even started
don't judge the idea trust that the idea
came to you for a reason so if i'm
thinking about somebody
in the shower somebody that maybe i met
yesterday or somebody that i haven't
talked to in three years
why am i thinking about that person uh i
don't know
italians have this expression they go
book means i don't know
so i trust that idea came for a reason
that idea is flowing through me for a
reason and i gotta do something about it
and so whenever i'm thinking about
somebody in the shower the next thing is
i get out of the shower and i'll email
that person right away and i'll always
make it awkward and say hey i was
thinking about you in the shower today
and then tell them what the story was
and it's never backfired on me
it's never backfired on me
sometimes it leads to some great
opportunity and sometimes it goes
nowhere but you get the idea you do
something get the idea you do something
stop judging the idea stop telling
yourself why you can't do it and then
step number three is take immediate
action and build momentum again the
biggest thing that you're just missing
is momentum you're a genius you're an
amazing entrepreneur you've got tons of
potential sarah blakely had this idea to
create spanx and it made her billionaire
when everybody thought she was crazy
right i'm sure you have ideas like that
too what's the difference between you
and her momentum
she did more she started she took the no
she took the rejection she took the
fears and she said i'm gonna give it my
shot
you need to build immediate momentum as
soon as you get that idea whether it's
in the shower on the walk on the drive
whatever it is as soon as you get that
you're not allowed to leave that moment
that moment of courage at one of
boldness a moment of feeling unstoppable
that moment like i can do this when
you're feeling that moment you're not
allowed to leave it without having done
something immediate action every single
time and sometimes that leads to
something great and maybe the momentum
falls off the next day that's okay but
in the moment
you have to take immediate action no
more excuses stop letting yourself off
the hook stop telling yourself that you
suck and you can't do it and go show
yourself that you can trying to get them
to focus upon positive things and we
sort of laid out a list of positive
things that she might think about and
she said oh abraham i don't want those
i've already got those
and what she really meant was
the things that i want are the things
that have not yet happened and we want
to help you to realize that if you're
thinking about things that you want from
the standpoint that they have not yet
come to fruition that they are still
missing in your experience
then you're holding it in a sort of
suspended position where the distance
between where you are and where it is is
not closing
so what we're wanting you to realize is
you have these patterns of thought and
law of attraction is helping you to
sustain
the pattern of thought that you have a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking and so early on in your
experience by your exposure to life you
began developing some patterns of
thought sometimes they were carefully
taught to you by others sometimes it
came because of something that you
observed and then talked about and then
remembered and then attracted again and
then talked about it and then remembered
and then attracted again in other words
life is very interesting here isn't it
because you can't talk about anything
for very long before it begins to
replicate itself in your life experience
and it's what makes you develop your
patterns of what you call truths
you say
at first i wasn't sure and then i
pondered it for a while
and once i gave it my attention
i began seeing evidence of it everywhere
and now i believe it and now that i
believe it it's manifesting in my
experience and we say that's really
wonderful isn't it if it's stuff you
want
but if you are repeating patterns of
thought about things you do not want
and in your environment oh you are very
very good at that you have this
sort of mass consciousness theory that
goes like this
if we don't beat the drum of our history
we are sure to repeat it again and we
say
the contrary is true
the more you beat the drum of anything
the more you activate it in your
vibration the more it is activated in
your vibration
then the more law of attraction is
matching you up with things like it and
the more law of attraction is matching
you up with things like it the more you
observe it and the more you observe it
the more you talk about it the more you
talk about it and observe it the more
you beat the drum of it or offer the
vibration of it the more you offer the
vibration of it the more law of
attraction matches you up with it the
more law of attraction matches you up
with it the more you're living it the
more you're talking about it the more
you're beating the drum of it the more
you're offering the vibration of it this
gathering we're calling it the art of
allowing but what it really means is the
art of telling a different story the art
of telling the story the way life has
helped you carve it out incrementally
but telling the story with your words
with your observations with your
expectations with your vibration
then when law of attraction is
responding to your deliberate offering
of thought now you're getting what you
want not just what you're observing
are there things in your life that are
as you want them to be
keep telling that story
are the things in your life that are not
as you want it to be
don't tell that story
you cannot choose something that feels
better until you are aware of what you
are choosing
so
relief is the order of business what do
you want to talk about life is a series
of changes those of us who are rigid and
inflexible in our thinking often snap
when the winds of change blow
but those of us who are like willow
trees
bend easily and adapt to the new changes
if we refuse to change then life passes
us by and we get left behind
just as a flexible body is more
comfortable to be in
so is a flexible mind more comfortable
to live in
i am open to the new and changing
every moment presents a wonderful new
opportunity to become more of who i am
i flow with life easily
and effortlessly
[Music]
i now go beyond other people's fears and
limitations
i am not my mother's fears and
limitations nor am i my father's fears
and limitations i'm not even my own
fears and limitations these are only
false thoughts that have been hanging
around in my mind
i can erase them as easily as i can
clean a dirty window
when the window of my mind is clean i
can see clearly the negative thoughts
for what they are and i can choose to
eliminate them
it is my mind that creates my
experiences
i am unlimited in my own ability to
create the good in my life
life mirrors my every thought
as i keep my thoughts positive life
brings me only good experiences
there is plenty for everyone including
me
there is so much food on this planet
that we could feed everyone
yes there are people who are starving
but it is not the lack of food it is the
lack of love that allows this to happen
there is so much money and so many
riches in the world far more than we
know
if it were all distributed equally
within a month or so those who have
money now would have more and those who
are poor now would once again be poor
for wealth has to do with consciousness
and deservability
there are billions of people on this
planet yet you will hear people tell you
that they are lonely
if we don't reach out love cannot find
us
so as i affirm my self-worth and my
deserve ability that which i need comes
to me in the perfect time space
availability
the ocean of life is lavish with its
abundance
all my needs and desires are met before
i even ask
my good comes from everywhere and
everyone and everything
all is well in my world
my life has always worked perfectly only
i did not know it i didn't realize that
every negative event in my world was
life reflecting back to me my belief
system
now that i am aware i can consciously
program my thinking process to have a
life that works on all levels
everything in my life works now and
forevermore
my work is deeply fulfilling
when we learn to love what we do then
life sees to it that we will always have
interesting creative occupations
when you are ready emotionally and
mentally for the next step in life life
will move you to it
give your best to life today
i do what i love and love what i do
i know that i am always working in the
right place with just the right people
and that i learn all of the valuable
lessons my soul needs to learn
life supports me
when you follow the laws of life life
will support you abundantly
life created me to be fulfilled i trust
life and life is always there at every
turn i am safe
my future is glorious
our futures will always represent our
current thoughts
what you are thinking and saying right
now is creating your future so think
glorious thoughts and you will have a
glorious future
i now live in limitless love light and
joy
all is well in my world
i open new doors to life
as i walk down the corridor of life
there are doors on every side each one
opens to a new experience
the more i clear the negative thought
patterns from my mind the more i find
doors that open to only good experiences
my clarity of thinking brings to me the
best that life has to offer
i rejoice in what i have
and i know fresh new experiences are
always ahead of me i greet the new with
open arms i trust life to be wonderful
i claim my own power and i lovingly
create my own reality
no one can do it for you
only you can make your own declarations
in your mind
if you give your power to others then
you have none when you claim your power
it is yours use it wisely
i ask for more understanding so that i
may knowingly and lovingly shape my
world and my experiences
i now create a wonderful new job
bless your current job with love and
release it with love to the next person
who takes your place
knowing that you are moving into a new
level of life
keep your affirmations for the new
position clear and positive and know
that you deserve the best
i am totally open and receptive to a
wonderful new position using my creative
talents and abilities working with and
for people i love in a wonderful
location and earning good money
everything i touch is a success
we always have the option of poverty
thinking or prosperity thinking
when we think thoughts of lack and
limitation then that is what we
experience
there is no way you can be prosperous if
your thinking is impoverished
to be successful you need to constantly
think thoughts of prosperity and
abundance
i now establish a new awareness of
success
i know i can be as successful as i make
my mind up to be
i move into the winning circle
golden opportunities are everywhere for
me prosperity of every kind is drawn to
me
i am open and receptive to new avenues
of income
when we are open and receptive life will
find many ways to bring income to us as
we know and affirm that we deserve all
good the infinite source will open new
channels
we often limit our own good by believing
in fixed income and other closed ideas
opening our consciousness opens the
banks of heaven
i now receive my good from expected and
unexpected sources i am an unlimited
being accepting from an unlimited source
in an unlimited way i am blessed beyond
my fondest dreams
i deserve the best and i accept the best
now
the only thing that keeps us from having
the good in our life is that we don't
believe we deserve it
somewhere in childhood we learned that
we didn't deserve and we believed it
now it is time to release that belief
i am mentally and emotionally equipped
to enjoy a prosperous and loving life it
is my birthright to deserve all good i
claim my good now
life is simple and easy
the laws of life are simple far too
simple for many people who want to
struggle and complicate things what you
give out comes back to you what you
believe about yourself and about life
becomes true for you
it is that simple
all i need to know at any given moment
is revealed to me i trust myself and i
trust life and all is well signs that
demystifies the mystical
and if you can combine a little quantum
physics with a little neuroscience with
neuroendocrinology with
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection epigenetics all of those
sciences point the finger at possibility
and
if you talk about religion if you talk
about culture if you talk about
tradition even spirituality i notice
that you divide an audience but science
in a sense creates community so people
come
for all kinds of reasons and what i've
learned in the last year or so is that
what people really want is wholeness
because when we want something or in
separation or in lack right
and so when we started
experimenting with doing different
scientific measurements
one of the things we started to notice
is that when a person
somehow connects
to something greater
and that has a influence on their
nervous system
the side effect is that they feel so
whole
so rejuvenated in that moment so blessed
by life
in that moment from an inner experience
that it's impossible for them to want i
mean how can you want
when you feel whole right and so when we
started looking at heart coherence and
we saw this
tremendous
changes in the
people's ability to be able to sustain
a state of mind a feeling in their heart
for an extended period of time
we have data to show you could be sick
and do that you could be a vegetarian
and do that you could be a carnivore and
do that you could be rich you could be
poor and it doesn't if you're skinny
overweight doesn't matter once you learn
that skill of self-regulation
and being able to experience a greater
level of wholeness
that if you can create from wholeness
instead of
separation or lack
you can produce greater effects
on the nature of reality so we came from
singularity and in when you're oneness
or when your source
there's no separation between cause and
effect your thoughts create experiences
when you're in oneness we journey down
the density and now we're really
separate from source
and so the
what what happens between cause and
effect is called time
so we're here now
to prove to ourselves that the divine
lives in us
so why not practice
shortening
time
or the interval between cause the
thought and the effect the experience
and when you start seeing something
appear in your life as a result of you
at cause
you start getting more kind
more caring more loving more conscious
more present
because you feel more whole there's a
primary law called the law of vibration
the law of vibration decrees that
everything in this universe moves
nothing rests
um the body in a coffin is moving uh
probably you're probably thinking this
guy's smoking something look if the body
in a coffin wasn't moving how would it
ever change to dust
it's always moving it's always vibrating
everything vibrates we live in a notion
of motion take a microscope and look at
a solid wall
it's not solid it only appears to be
solid a perception problem there you'll
see the wall moving right in front of
your eyes there's a particle of energy
and they're dancing right before your
eyes that's a lot of vibration the law
of vibration decrees everything moves
nothing rests we literally live in a
notion of motion
now this physical instrument we're
living in we call our body is a
molecular structure and it's in a very
high speed of vibration
our brain is an electronic switching
station
when we activate brain cells we alter
the vibration in different parts of the
body i could not move my hand up and
down or my arm up and down without first
giving a message to my brain to do that
well the brain
activates cells in the body it sets up a
vibration in the body
the vibration that the mind and body are
in is going to dictate what you attract
because when you put yourself in a
vibration what you're really doing is
put yourself on a specific frequency
that's what you do when you set a goal
most people set a goal and then wait for
it to happen and never going to happen
you've got to assume that it's already
happened you've got a picture of it in
your mind mentally it's already happened
it's happened because i've got the idea
in my conscious mind if i didn't have
the idea of my conscious mind i couldn't
talk to you about it the very fact i can
talk to you about it means that i've
already got it
then i've got to get emotionally
involved in it
i'm already emotionally involved in the
goal that i've got i've got it
intellectually i've got it emotionally
it's only a period of time till it moves
into form how does it move into form
well you attract whatever is required
for it to move into form you attract all
the energy that's necessary to produce
the physical result how do you do that
you do that by intellectually
emotionally staying in the vibration
of the good that you desire you see it
already in the present tense so that
keeps you on the frequency
and that frequency then dictates what
you're going to attract you can only
attract to you what's in harmonious
vibration with you
now if you're holding an image that you
can't get something you're on a
vibration
you're not going to get it but if you
can see yourself with it you know it's
coming to you you know it you know it's
only a period of time you're not quite
sure what the time is but you know it's
a period of time and bang that thing's
going to manifest in your life
you have controlled the vibration that
you're in
the vibration then called the frequency
you put yourself in the frequency that
you good your desires on
let's suppose i want to have a lot of
money we're just talking about money now
this is a lot of money relative to let's
say
this there's one 100 here's 10 100 100.
so one's a lot relative to the other
neither one is a lot it just is
if i want to attract a lot of my i got
to see myself with a lot of money i got
to mentally accept i've already got it i
don't let my bank account dictate that
i choose that
so i'm choosing myself to see myself
with the good i already desire i'm on
that frequency now the trick is to stay
on that frequency
most people look at the results and they
let the results dictate the frequency
they're on that's why they keep getting
the same results
they have the image in their mind
they're already reached the goal they
want they're already successful and
somebody else comes along say well you
haven't got those results
in my mind i have but they're not
looking in my mind they're looking at my
present results and then pretty soon i
start listening to them i think god
they're right i look at my results i
haven't got it
do you see why we keep getting this poor
results
you've got to see yourself with the good
you desire you've got to hold that image
in your mind you've got to know it's
going to come and that will attract
everything that's necessary see nothing
is created or destroyed everything's
already here if not in one frequency
certainly in another or not in one state
certainly in another we've got to get on
the frequency of the good that we desire
when you think a deliberate thought of
what you want
then law of attraction will employ the
universe and all people circumstances
and events
to
move you to what you've asked for and to
move what you've asked for to you
and so
if
if you think about that
there is just action
would be really really hard for you to
reach all of the people circumstances
and events manipulate all of them to
receive what you want and if you really
reflect well on your life and things
that have happened in your life you'll
kind of see
that
actually that happened for me
ah all i did was move to here or all i
did was move to there and
i received what i wanted
thought creates all of the appearances
in the world and thought creates
everything in your life
so it's pretty darn powerful
right
and what you think about is what you get
what you focus on is what will manifest
in your life and everyone is manifesting
their day every single day we're doing
it um we are not aware of course
necessarily of thoughts but
thoughts come we energize them and then
they will manifest unless we
cancel that thought out
um
with another thought with a thought that
contradicts it but i remember lester
levinson would say
every single thought manifests
and i just thought that was incredible i
had known the secret for years and years
and years and lester levinson was a real
master
um and he said every single thought
manifests and i was just wow
that's how powerful they are
so
so thoughts are your superpower
to be do and have
what you want to experience and have and
do in your life
and and so if you ask
um an athlete or if you talk to a coach
a really brilliant coach right of a
sports team then you will find that
visualization and these principles that
i'm talking about are a big part of
their training
they have to be they have to see
themselves winning the game they have to
see themselves winning the match there
is a really incredible tennis player
that's a very big fan
a champion tennis player that's a really
big fan of the secret who uses the
sacred this is what he does he sees that
he's won the match before he walks out
onto that court
and and it's the same for
um
for teams it's the same for athletes in
the olympic games running a race and
seeing that they've won yes they run the
race but
what has them win the race is that
they saw themselves winning before they
even got on the starting block
and they saw it and believed it and felt
it and so they just everything lined up
for them in the perfect way they drew
the perfect lane everybody else was was
moved in exactly the right position and
they got a really great start and they
won the race
and so
thought is just so so powerful so
athletes but also do you know the
astronauts in the apollo
program did visualization before they
went to the moon and
they visualized landing back on earth
safely
and so that's how important the
visualization visualization is just
thought in pictures by the way it's it's
it's still thought it's just the same
thing okay it's just thought in pictures
so if you took a person who had
zero resistance
and you lock them in a room
you know if you took a person that had
zero resistance that person thought
about what they wanted zero resistance
lock them in a room what they wanted
will come to them
the universe will move people
circumstances and events and bring that
right to them
it absolutely must
because if you have no resistance you
have unleashed a law that just cannot be
stopped
and so you will manifest it will come to
you i once heard a definition of health
that made a lot of sense to me
good health it said
is having no fatigue
having a good appetite
going to sleep and awakening easily
having a good memory
having good humor
and having precision in thought and
action
not being
being honest
humble
grateful and loving
how healthy are you
i do not heal anyone
the work i do is to help people
understand how their own mental patterns
are constantly creating their own life
experiences
all of them
the good experiences
and the so-called bad experiences
and also
how these same mental patterns
are contributing to the ease
and dis-ease
in their bodies
we do not want to be ill
and yet we need every disease we have
it is the body's way of telling us that
we have a false idea in consciousness
our body is telling us we are on the
wrong track
and need to change the way we think
every illness
is a lesson
for us to learn
please do not just complain i want to
get rid of this condition
it will not create the healing you want
nor will you learn the lesson you need
to learn
this is not a time for condemnation
or for creating more guilt
we are just looking at what needs to be
released
this is a time for healing
for making our lives and our bodies
whole
i know
you have within you all that you need to
accomplish this
once we begin to understand this process
we are able to take conscious control
of the changes we wish to make in our
lives
this is a very exciting process
and becomes one of the most important
adventures in our lives
i believe there is a center of wisdom
within each one of us
and when we are ready to make positive
changes in our lives
we attract whatever we need to help us
something inside of you has shifted
and the healing process has already
begun
you might even say that to yourself now
i have already begun
the healing process
the body like everything else in life
is a mirror of our inner thoughts and
beliefs
the body is always talking to us if we
will only take the time to listen
every cell
responds to every single thought you
think
and every word you speak
continuous modes of thinking and
speaking
produce body behaviors and postures and
eases or dis-eases
the person who has a permanently
scowling face
did not produce that
by having joyous loving thoughts
older people's faces and bodies
show so clearly a lifetime of inner
dialogue
how will you look
when you are elderly
you see it is my belief that it is our
birthright to be totally healthy
and totally fulfilled
in every area of our lives take a nice
deep breath
and if possible
allow yourself to be in a comfortable
position
just let these ideas wash over you
only those ideas that are right for you
will be accepted by you
it doesn't matter whether you understand
them all or not
or if they make sense to you right now
your subconscious mind will hear and
record whatever you need
i believe that all illness is
self-created
not that we say i want to have this
illness
but we create a mental atmosphere where
this dis-ease can grow and flourish
our internal mental dialogue
reacts in every cell
in the body
i heard a physician say recently
if the surgeon operates on a patient
without doing something to help them
change the cause of the disease
then all the doctor is doing is
prolonging the life of the patient
until the patient can create another
dis-ease
you see we need to do more than just
treat the symptom
we need to eliminate the cause of the
dis-ease
and for that we need to go within
ourselves where the process of illness
began
it is my belief that we are each
responsible for every experience in our
lives
the best and the worst
we all create our experiences by the
thoughts we think and the words we speak
the universe totally supports our
internal dialogue
our subconscious mind accepts as truth
whatever we choose to believe
you can say it either way
they both mean that what i believe about
myself and about life becomes true for
me
what you choose to think about yourself
and about life becomes true for you
manifesting is acquiring the experience
of what it is that you want to feel and
being and living and believing in that
experience and then allowing that
experience to come into form sometimes
we manifest things far beyond our
wildest dreams so sometimes if we have a
vision of something it happens in a far
greater way so we want to stay open yep
so we can say i want that macbook air
but maybe we get that macbook air that's
a little bit bigger than we thought yeah
or maybe it comes with an extra little
gift yeah but allowing ourselves to be
open this or something more manifesting
is very creative it is the process of
using your power energy and being in
that presence of your high-powered
energy and allowing that energy to
co-create with the energy that's around
you so you're vibrating at a high
frequency
i'm vibrating at high frequencies we've
done a lot of work we've cleaned up a
lot of our own crap we believe in
ourselves today and that that energy of
believing in ourselves has attracted us
together today and brought us into this
space where we together are co-creating
and teaching if i hadn't cleaned up my
side of the street if i didn't believe
in myself the way i do i would never
have manifested being on marietv
miracles occur naturally and when
they're not occurring something has gone
wrong
that's interesting it's a good one right
so what happens is that that
synchronicity that flow that effortless
action that just sort of allowing oh i
was thinking about that and it just
showed up that's how life is supposed to
be
we get in the way our negative belief
systems our fears our anxiety our anger
towards the past that future tripping
and projecting all of that energy gets
in the way of allowing all of the
miracles to occur naturally so the first
type of manifestation is to get very
very clear and you know if we're not
clear about what we desire then we can
call in some really funky stuff you must
be clear because if you are unclear
you'll start to call in some things that
are not really what you want you'll be
confused uh the other piece is that once
you're clear you can also then get clear
about all the ways that you don't
believe
all of the limiting beliefs all the
negativity that might be blocking you
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below
on this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
if you want to learn how to activate the
law of attraction check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there everybody at least kind of in the
mass market
what you're trained to think about when
you think about manifesting is vision
boards and when you hear the word vision
boards you think about